I had um oh she's a kid too and I used
to like eat french fries and then bite
it to the bottom and the nub that I
touched I'd put in a pile
how is that
I used to not we'll have it I had it
really bad to the point that I would
have to run up and down my stairs eight
times before I left no I didn't do that
that's psychotic I'd have to like flip
my light switch up and down a certain
amount of check in the oven and stuff
and I had to like go unplug it okay plug
it back in unplug it replug it why did
you unplug it yes you did now you're
plugging it back in just to make sure
that you're actually unplugging it oh my
God it's weird yeah I'm very
neurotic
foreign